[Musik]
wir sind alle befreundet und meisten
habenben Interessen und wir teilen
natürlich alle Leidenschaft die Musik
eben und es ist extrem schön und
cool ich habe viel gefunden mit dem ich
nicht gerechnet hätte ich habe Freunde
gefunden hoffentlich fürs Leben ich habe
einen wahnsinnigen menhalt
gefunden was mich auch glaube ich aufs
spätere Leben sehr sehr gut vorbereitet
ist dass man bei den diversesten
unterschiedlichsten Aufgaben die wir zu
erfüllen haben ob das jetzt eine
angelebung ist eine Rasenshow oder ein
Konzert man muss immer 100% Leistung
bringen und das bereitet mich glaube ich
optimal auf ein späteres Berufsleben vor
[Musik]
Musik also ichin bei termusik weil es
noch der Matur auf alle Fälle eine gute
Chance ist das Jahr bis zum Studium zu
[Musik]
überbrücken wir haben Auftritte von
militärischer militärischen Festakten
Zapfenstreich bis hin zu
Benefizkonzerten das sind an der Zahl
250 im
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Jahr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zu einem Drittel besteht das Orchester
aus Kadersoldaten und zu zweit dr
besteht das Orchester aus grundwertinnen
bzw MZ Militärpersonen auf Zeit das ist
einfach wunderschön zum sehen wir sie
die LE eben bei uns entwickeln also
nicht nur als Berufsorchester zum spüen
sondern eben als
ausbildungsorchester es gibt die mal
Gehörbildung und Theorie und man lernt
so die Basics im stabführen und im
dirigieren wo sie heute natürlich auch
wieder positiv auswirkt weil die meisten
von uns eben Kapelle hab der haben in
der sie spülen und aktiv
sein
mein persönliches Highlight sind immer
die die symphonischen Konzerte in die
diversesten konzertzele in ganz
[Musik]
nösterreich